some people describe
mev minor extractable value as an
existential risk to ethereum
what is mev how important is it to solve
mav
if it's important what ideas do you have
sure um how about after this one we'll
also talk about sharding because that's
amazing and it's part of your return
back to sharding and
which is no you know return to the big
picture of the scaling problem as you
mentioned
i love i love this conversation you know
depth first search instead of breadth
first
so uh basically okay ebbyv
minor extractable value um it is not
different in proof of work and proof of
stake right so like if you want to call
it
you know block proposer extractable
value like it sounds a lot sexy but you
know we can call it b-path instead of
math who cares
um but so this is a problem in both
proof-of-work and proof-of-stake
yes so the basic idea is
that if you have the ability to choose
which transactions go into a block and
in what order
then you have the ability to like take
advantage of that position for economic
gain
in a lot more ways than just collecting
transaction fees right
like for example there's decentralized
exchanges on chain like uniswap
and like let's say the price of eth
versus usdc was 2700
the previous block but then there was a
bit of a market drop and now it's 26.80
where you can go on uniswap and you can
just like gobble up the entire part of
um you know the automated order book
that's like between
2700 and 26.80 right and that's and then
at the same time you like run a bot and
uh you know you buy some east back at
26.80 and you've just like made about 10
dollars of profit right so
or well ten dollars times you know
whatever the depth is right so and
so there's lots of um little things like
that there's also things um that involve
like
front running other people's
transactions so one example of this
would be
that if someone sends a transaction that
says
buy me five eth for um
whatever price that you can get um then
but with a maximum of
let's say yeah uh fifteen thousand
dollars then you can go and like
you can send each put a transaction
right in front of that transaction
and you can like buy up that east first
and then you resell it to him at you
know fifteen thousand dollars minus one
yeah
so there's you get to make a little bit
of money exactly so there's a lot of
these different like arbitrage front
running back running these different
tricks
that allow block proposers to to get
some percentage
on top like overhead exactly and the
reason why this is
a challenge is because um
it's like first of all it's some it
sometimes degrades
user experience because users get you
know less favorable uh
trades but there are sometimes ways to
like mitigate that for applications
sometimes it's not that bad
but like the bigger risk that i think
some people consider more existential
is that there's just much more economies
of scale
in figuring out how to extract all this
revenue because if you're just
collecting transaction fees
there aren't really economies of scale
there aren't really benefits to
centralizing right because it's a very
simple formula you just like grab up the
transactions that pay you the most
but with mev you know you have there's
all these sophisticated algorithms
and if you have lots of money then you
can hire really smart people to make
amazing algorithms and then you can use
the other half of your money
to get a lot of mining power or a lot of
stake and you get a lot of opportunities
to use your even better algorithms
so there's this risk that like as a
result
of this mining is basically or
or even validating proof of stake is
going to centralize um
so i think the ecosystems best reply to
this sort of risk and it's the direction
where
projects like flashbots are going
already is
if you can't eliminate the
centralization
then you try to firewall it right and
the way that you fire wallet is
you basically say we're going to try to
deliberately create a marketplace where
people can just do the complicated work
of creating what are called bundles like
bundles of transactions that like are
very profitable right
and then at the other side of the market
you just have
like block proposes reminders that are
just dumb nodes and they go and ask
the what are called searchers the bundle
creators and they just ask like hey
like how much can you give me if i put
in your bundle and then they just take
the highest offer
right so you sort of separate out the
task and you know you have
the easy part and then you have the hard
part and you have like this special
class of actor called a searcher that
does the hard part
and then the easy part the people doing
the easy part which is just miners and
validators they
kind of just talk to all the different
people
doing the searching and they just you
know accept the highest bidder right
so and this is also just like
interesting uh an interesting example of
like economic design philosophy right
like
sometimes you can't just like make
centralization go away sometimes it's
inevitable but
you know at least you can try to kind of
contain it you can direct it
or you know you can even sort of
firewall it away from
you know core consensus the parts that
really do need to be decentralized
so but you don't see it as an
existential risk it's just incredible
it's it's a bit of a problem that it has
to be constantly dealt with
it's a i mean it's a risk like there's
obviously a risk that you know there it
it's a very severe problem and that even
this flashbots approach has some fatal
flaw or whatever
um but i'm definitely like
we're definitely approaching it with the
mindset of you know this is a problem
and like yes we do have to do some work
to solve it but we're doing it
and so far it's being solved
you